Ladies and gentlemen of NASA, this is Charles Xavier.
Help is on the way.
We're doing space missions now.
Cool.
We get the astronauts we bring them home.
Go.
Heat signatures rising fast.
We got to get out of here.
Where's Jean?
Where is she?!?
Jean!
She should be dead.
Did you hear what the kids are calling you?
Phoenix.
Hello Jean.
Who are you?
The better question is, who are you?
Something's happening to me.
When I lose control, bad things happen.
Well, it feels good.
That power destroyed everything it ever came into contact with....
...until you.
The X-Men fear you.
...and what they fear...
...they seek to destroy.
She'll kill us all.
A girl dies.
She's still our friend.
She's not Jean anymore.
That's right.
That would be a bad idea.
Jean!